so I love my dad I love my dad very very
much and he is an oil man from Boston
Massachusetts and he actually owns his
own oil tank removal company called
tanks a lot that's completely real tanks
a lot he goes to the same Dunkin Donuts
every single morning and he loves to
leave me voicemails would you guys like
to hear a real voicemail that my father
left me you guys want to do that on
Sunday morning in Boston Massachusetts
we're having a roundtable discussion
airily come up with a sitcom feel it's
called the public storage Duncan falling
I'm gonna have a little dr. Norton
reasons were published green screens
indoor public storage facility and the
people in the people is in storage urine
Singh or down to drug indoors they're
gonna have a hard time telling their
stories we leave out the prostitute that
resident a place where choose your thing
in a public garden for a right ah no I
call you only because I could I guess
have a nice day call your mother done
love it